it's all about mindset I would have many
shitty days I mean any top athlete will
tell you that many many shitty days I've
dealt with Lyme disease chronic injuries
so how can you find something positive
that you can still make a step forward
in some capacity whether that's mentally
or physically you know it's
understanding how your brain works what
suits you what doesn't how to still find
kind some kind of momentum even when
you're having a bad day um and maybe
that's I'm I'm such a positive person I
love to find the positivity in anything
you know my dad's pretty pretty tough
Scottish man that real Scottish you know
bring people down that were successful
whereas my mom is the opposite right
gushing and everything's
amazing you you kind of strike the
balance between both uh but they create
your driving force to understand how to
find positivity in any situation